I might need a running start
okay that wasn't that bad at all
Peter our intern disappeared for once
not my fault
Peter's not noon is that Peter I know
who you're gonna have
normally be like alright we'll see him
in like 10-15 minutes maybe he went to
the local store down the street but it's
been like an hour or two think it's been
like two hours do you think you found it
it's like a little Reaper from Mass
Effect this is called the Samsung gear
360 and it is a 360-degree camera one of
the coolest things I like to do with the
360 camera is to make like the little
planet effect and for that you need a
sky so we're gonna go up to the roof so
it's pretty centered and we're all just
going to be in a circle around it just
dance like idiots
to 190 degree field of view lenses
capture everything in this direction and
everything in that direction and then
using the software you stitch together
it's actually really easy to stitch you
just drop it in the software it does it
for you the software comes with the 360
camera you can't actually buy it
anywhere I tried so here's the shot I
literally just recorded as you can see
it's two fisheye shots and I'm going to
throw this into software that'll stitch
it together into a neck we rectangular
map and boom 360 video ready go one out
bottom of the ninth and they want me to
go up we're one point away from winning
but my batting average isn't what it
used to be no one out bottom of the
ninth and they want me to go up we're
one point away from winning but my
batting average isn't what it used to be
now put me here for a reason I just need
to get to first and it'll be smooth
sailing from there we're talking about
red vs. blue
I mean dodges V Angels Dodgers are
bigger than angel Dodgers u Red Sox
that's like pretty britain pretty blue
oh we forgot Crips me Bloods oh forget
it red coast vs. blue coats Democrats
Republicans Pokemon firefighters versus
cops Walmart vs. target coke versus
Pepsi Team Fortress 2 Facebook versus
YouTube Crips vs. Bloods Dodgers vs. Red
Sox rocketjump vs. quarter digital
obi-wan vs. Darth Vader lightsaber
colors Iron Man which is Captain America
Mario vs. onic Elmo versus Cookie
Monster Nazi flag versus Israeli flag
hello
I got lost I got lost in he got lost I
swear to god I'll show you in my maths
history I was just trying to go to
McDonald's and I went there and I was
trying to come back and i missed the
turn and then my phone was gonna die and
so I had to figure it out for myself
and I went off of a poster for the pets
movie and that giant building right
there and I found my way back wait you
don't have a car charger no no no kids
just is Iron Man it's gonna shoot the
militia man and then the captain erisa
play what this is comments-section goal
but I read through it I was like that
actually worked quite nicely however is
none of yours inaudible unavoidably
clear message that it is now an
anti-prom video similar shot I guess
will be the energy source if that we
have that for bread sheet right it's so
much cooler if it's an energy so I don't
waste a lightsaber you're saying if you
want to ever so you want it to be this
red character from red versus blue is
just a reference it's not like a it's
not like it these are the characters
from a reference book it's just it's
just a hey look it's red and blue chief
just like in red versus blue and then
just kind of ending it they're just
saying I strongly recommend not
deviating it's like their only form of
character is their weapon okay yeah well
I noticed you had the energy sword which
I thought was a good idea at home whoa
hot both got the either it's an energy
sword or gone bad doesn't matter rifle
I've got the energy sword yeah
the funny thing is is he doesn't even
use his weapon in the video he just
stands there with him like he's about to
use it and then obi-wan you hear a
sniper shot rang out and everyone turns
into a pile close to then just gives
- there's a visual idea of like it with
the lightsaber in a horse with plasma
sword it's like it's like people like oh
ho ha ha see I could get ultimate gum
game that's that same thing Athene so
he's got a gun oh maybe a sword Brendan
we'll find out when we come back I'm
joking yeah um we like dust off it was
good